i have a lot of energy because
i i literally have been typing into
these slides
like three seconds ago so um
i'm hyped about how this is gonna go
so this talk is about creating uh
add-ons for node
um how many people know what add-ons for
node are
uh okay cool cool lots of people um
so essentially add-ons are the node
version of c
extension so you can take see uh c code
c libraries
and expose them as javascript apis um
i'm kind of going out of order here so
we'll we'll see um
uh who am i first of all i'm marco
rodgers
very newly minted started working at uh
at yammer
uh in san francisco so um
i'm also like one of the node guys from
very early days i was like lurking
on the mailing list when it first showed
up and like
you know remember 0.1.33 which really
kind of felt like it was a node and that
you could use it for something
useful and it stayed 3-3 for a long time
so i've been around for a while i kind
of fell into doing node add-ons
it's kind of a story but we don't have a
lot of time i have a tremendous amount
of slides
and i don't even we're not going to make
it through those because i want to do
something
else too so um so let's keep it moving
um i'm also the maintainer of lib xml js
one of the biggest node add-ons easily
one of the most complex it is bindings
to lib xml2
which is the giant like you know super
compliant uh c library for dealing with
xml and html people familiar with that
pretty much
so okay uh and just a shout out to
jeff smick who actually started the
project uh handed her it over to me
at a certain point so i'm the primary
maintainer now but i just wanted i
wanted to
give him a shout out real quick um so
let's go through the kind of boilerplate
stuff and then we'll look at
what kind of an add-on looks like and
then i really want to kind of pull up
some
code and look at it because the reason
i'm doing this talk let me kind of just
take a segue
the reason i'm doing this talk is
because no one else was doing this talk
um and node add-ons are actually i think
extremely important
um there's not a lot of community around
them yet and we we need to make more of
them so
i'm the guy that's not afraid to stand
up here and look stupid while i talk to
you about it
and like because you know i don't have
all the knowledge that i need so i need
to bring you guys in so that's what i'm
trying to do
right um okay so an add-on is just
simply a way to bind c
c plus classes or functions into
javascript okay
a better definition a way to enable new
js apis
based on existing code and that's a
simple distinction but it's important
because
we'll see in a little bit you can create
you can and you should
create your javascript api the way that
you want it to be
rather than looking at the library and
say what does this do let me map this
straight into javascript right
uh and uh most importantly i think
just for the purposes of organization a
node add-on
when you create a node add-on you get a
you get one file and it's like something
dot node
that's the extension uh and node sees
that as a
module that it's gonna require and it's
going to have exports hanging off of it
just like any other node module that you
guys are familiar with
so that's also important and we'll come
back to that
okay so why would anyone want to do this
i just thought that this was something
that i wanted to throw out there um
see plus plus code is really fast
everybody likes that uh writing it makes
you feel kind of like a badass
especially if you are you know strictly
a front end guy like
haven't done c since college i'm
describing myself
um and then i jumped into it and i was
like all right i can do this right
but um it it's hard
um and the people who know see here are
going to be like
well you can leave sorry because it
sucks
and it's frustrating and but it's
awesome because when you
get into it when you get back into it
and you feel you see stuff working
and you run a test of a javascript
module versus a c module and you get
like
you know two orders of magnitude speed
up you feel like a badass
right so um the third point i think is
the most important which is c
in c plus code actually exists
and runs and works right now whereas
we're working with javascript
which doesn't have any libraries right
so
the reason i'm giving this talk and the
reason that you guys should be writing
writing add-ons
is to make libraries for node right
instead of writing them in javascript
which is really fun and really cool
use the ones that are already there and
that work and are battle tested
and they're way fast right so um and
finally you can
speak intelligently about why you hate
to write c and c
plus which i do all the time so um
so for the for the majority of these
examples i'm gonna be using um bcrypt
people are familiar with bcrypt pretty
much uh so essentially
it allows you to encrypt data using um
blowfish in coding algorithms right
and it's really simple the the the
signatures for b-crypt kind of look like
this these are the two major functions
right
you can generate assault by passing it a
number
and you can um call b crypt which is
going to
take a the first string which is the the
thing that you want to encrypt
the second string which is the salt the
second string which is the salt
uh and it's going to return you the
encrypted version i'm using
s5 for slides here so it's going to give
me crap right now
quick shout out to nick campbell who's a
friend of mine i wanted to use be crypt
for one because it's pretty simple the
api is simple but
it's also very useful and we can focus
on the add-on rather
than the library itself because this is
the signature that's it
we can move on to the next thing and
talk about how we're going to
expose it in node um and also nick
campbell is a good friend of mine and
i'm going to
if we have time kind of tear into his
version of bcrypt
and how we might be able to improve it
and he'd be good-natured about that so i
thought that was a good idea
um and if you want to learn more about
bcrypt uh click on this link
um where uh coda hale who actually also
works at yammer i thought it'd be cool i
threw his link up there it's from like
years ago before i knew who he was and
that's how i learned about bcrypt so
that's cool
um all right so uh we're gonna write an
add-on
and essentially it's gonna work like
this
we're going to require bcrypt and that's
going to be our add-on module
it's going to have a you know a class
hanging off of it that is decrypt
um we're going to skip the salt stuff i
just have my own salt here
create a bcrypt object and then call
encrypt
one function that's not gonna work um
one function you call and you get you
pass it a password you get assault
and you're good to go right that's
that's 85 of what you need out of out of
this module
right um so pretty simple we should we
should be able to get it done
um how does it work so
like i said when you create a module
when you when you when you successfully
get your module to compile
you're gonna get one file that says
bcrypt.node or whatever you decided to
name it
bcrypt.node when you
require modules in node it searches
through the pass it finds them
and it tries to load them up when it
sees dot node
it immediately treats that as an add-on
and calls dl open
if you're jumping into c you'll find out
about dl open i'm not going to talk
about it because
it makes my head hurt and then
inside your add-on we'll see this
there's an init function
right and that's your entry point and to
see into loading up your
c module as an add-on and we'll see that
and it basically it essentially behaves
like a module except you get and and you
pass in an export object
and you enhance that exports object and
pass it back from c
right so it's essentially you you get a
module like like you expect in node
with an object that has methods and
properties hanging off of it so
it should be pretty familiar um
let's see uh so let's let's kind of jump
kind of jump in
um i want to look at some code in in a
second but i want to go through the kind
of basic stuff right
um so this is javascript um and it's
running in v8 and it's a simple function
it says encrypt
um this is bound to whatever the context
is if there is one
uh there are some arguments you can
check the arguments uh
object and you can pull them out um and
then you return something
very simple 101 right here's what that
looks like
in v8 um
this is c plus plus um
if every time i look at it i i
try to like i have to encourage myself
to keep doing it
but um it looks like this right so
bcrypt here
is a c plus class and encrypt is the
function that's hanging off of it
and this is the part that looks funky
right this is the this is essentially
the crux of the v8
api which is um you call c
plus functions and they have this method
signature and there's this
arguments object and that's in v8 and
this is their encapsulation of what we
just saw
right which is we've got this argument
object that um
that represents the the variable number
of arguments that will that were passed
into this function
and then we do something with them and
we return something so
this arguments object has some
some methods off of it that let you do
essentially the same thing um
because of the way c plus plus works and
because javascript is so dynamic and the
context is going to change
you can't use the regular c plus this uh
so the v8 guys they hung it off of the
argument's object so that's how you can
always get to
this which is a handle and we're going
to talk about that in a minute
um i'm creating the same kind of
variable here with an args1
uh i missed a step but you can check the
length
you can pull arguments out of the args
uh object because it it acts as an array
right so you can index it
um you have to worry about types a lot
in v8 right javascript types are really
simple
c and c plus plus types are not uh
and that's going to be a big deal and
that's something that i really want to
kind of get you guys feedback on
if again if we have the time so
um you know you can set you set some
some parameters uh
you create some variables set some
parameters and then how we added these
two strings together here really simply
uh we need to use a function for that
and see so their string
string.concat and you pass it to a
v8 string objects we can create a new
one on the fly and then we pass our
variable whether it's
defaulted or whether it was passed in so
that makes sense to everybody
is that mapping go for it
uh yes that that's a problem that's a
typo sorry like i said
three seconds ago i was doing this uh
yes this should be args
here is is what he said so um
we're gonna see real working code in a
little bit so hopefully it'll be better
um let's go all right uh let's talk
about some concepts that we're that
we're seeing here right
the type of this um variable
is a handle and it should actually have
a um
a template parameter on it this is not a
c
plus plus tutorial so i'm not even going
to go into how that works
uh but you'll learn the kind of
boilerplate stuff
and eventually it'll make sense
but um so essentially it it kind of
works like this
v8 is running a javascript uh you know
environment
on a heap all javascript values are on a
heap
right so when you're dealing with them
in
your c plus plus functions you deal with
handles and handle is a local
reference to javascript values on the
heap right so
everything that you deal with that is a
javascript value is going to go through
handles and then you can
you essentially unwrap them to get at
the c types underneath them
we'll see a little bit of that hopefully
um but like i said i really want to get
to the kind of the meat of things right
um this is kind of what i exactly what i
just said about handles
you need to unwrap handles to get to the
data there's also handle scopes the
reason that v8 went with this and
if you know anything about spider monkey
they don't have any kind of concept like
this
the reason v8 went with this is that
they want to make it easy for
you to clean up your references so that
they don't
leak and the way that they do that is to
have everything in a handle and a handle
is a handle make sure that you're going
through the right
you know i mean it's a name named
appropriately it's a handle to
whatever you're dealing with and you
always go through that handle and they
can track handles
and the way that they do that is through
this handle scope object
you create a handle scope and every time
you get a handle
this object is going to track it and
when it goes out of scope by popping off
you know pop this function pops off the
stack
it's going to clean out all those
handles right so it keeps you from
having
a lot of memory leaks it also creates a
lot of headaches
uh and we'll we'll maybe talk about that
in a little bit right
um if i'm going too fast please let me
know but you know i really want to kind
of blaze and then see if we can see some
code right
there's two types of handles there's
local handles which like i said are
really important for cleaning up
your temporary objects that you're
dealing with in javascript
um those get collected as usual by
um you know by a a c stack popping off
um and then there are persistent handles
because you want to
you want to have you know when you get
to your final destination of your you
know your return value
you want to have that persist so it can
go back into
the javascript environment and doesn't
get collected right because it's going
to get collected unless there is a
javascript reference to it
so you need to use persistent handles to
make sure that
you know if you're dealing with stuff in
javascript you jump into c
plus land and start doing something
meanwhile the
v8 garbage collector decides to run and
it says oh you're not using this i'll
just clean it up
then you're effed right you're kind of
screwed so um
all right so um the way that you deal
with that
handle scopes and uh handles
is like this and this this slide made
made more sense earlier but you create a
handle scope by just
you know doing a local initialization of
it and as soon as you do this this is
the only line that you need
you're tracking handles within this
function right every handle you create
within this function
is gonna get tracked and it's gonna get
cleaned up when the function ends
um so this is actually the way this
worked out is kind of a patch file
because what i had
before i before i knew better what i had
was just okay i'm just going to return a
v8 array right like so
create a new array basically like the
empty brackets that we all know from
javascript and return it
and it was working fine 80 of the time
until the garbage collector got to it
and then it was gone
and i was seg-faulting right so that's
what happens like
it's gonna let you drag these handles
around all the time until you
try to use them and the data underneath
has been collected
and it craps out that's what happens so
what you have to do is create scopes
make sure things get cleaned up and then
you have to close the scope
it's misnamed i think but essentially
what it means is
this is a local handle but i'm going to
pass it to the calling scope
because i know that it's my return value
right so
you take this scope and you say okay for
this handle i know you have it tracked
and you're going to try to screw me
on this close it pass it back right so
this is very important there are a lot
of patches
in lib xml js just doing this right and
if you forget it you will have problems
um uh so okay uh next kind of concept i
want to
talk about really quick is well how do
you deal with
objects right you you have your cd
library it might be a c
plus library and they have classes and
you're going to want to hang some state
off of those classes and you're going to
get to them when you when your extension
calls your c methods right
the way that you do that um or at least
the the node way that we're providing
to do that is through node object wrap
and you know to kind of keep things
simple all this does
is take a c plus class and wrap it in a
v8 handle
right so you can pass that handle around
and it'll act like an object when it's
in js
js land when you call in when you call
into a c function
you take that handle and you unwrap it
and you get your c plus plus object back
uh it's really convenient um it there's
a there's a lot of like
tricky sea magic going on in there if
you're if you're not fan of heart jump
in there and take a look
but it's it's it's grimy so just you
know do what it says
so all right and uh i mean basically it
has two functions on it right
it has wrap and it has unwrapped so
object wrap dot unwrap basically is
gonna take this
this this context that's coming in with
this function
and that's a v8 handle right unwrap says
okay unwrap this and give me back my
c plus object which is a b crypt and
again
i've left the templatization off of here
you have to tell it what you're
unwrapping and we'll see that in real
code in a little bit but
as soon as you do this you're you're
back in c land and you can do whatever
you want with this
pointer to ubcrypt object so all right
um
there are a lot of classes and utilities
that node gives you to be able to
um approximate what you expect in node
in the c in c and c plus plus land um
things like event emitters are there so
you can subclass in a ventimeter on your
c plus plus class
and make it act like an event emitter uh
and see you're calling emit
and you're giving it you know the the
name closed and
um the callback thing is a little a
little
a little different that's on the other
side of emit but
we're not going to get to that because
there's a lot and we only have a half a
half hour and i'm already
what 20 minutes in so um but on the
other side this is javascript and
i didn't you know i didn't uh these
these slides are super new so
this is a new connection in javascript
this represents your connection c
plus class you're making a new one and
you're treating it just like an event
emitter
right so it's going to go through c code
it's going to emit whatever you want it
to emit
and it behave when once it comes out of
the module it behaves like node and it's
awesome
right so um if you if you learn the the
kind of paradigms and the the techniques
to you know write your modules such that
they behave like node
your white write way better add-ons and
people will be really happy
um there's lots of other stuff i'm going
to start like breathing just a little
bit like yeah okay i'm so i'm at the end
there's lots to cover here
i didn't go through throwing exceptions
right you need to do that
object wrap also has a ref uh you know
it's kind of a reference counting thing
where you can
when you have to do asynchronous actions
and you're essentially
off of the v8 thread to keep your to
keep
your uh to keep the garbage collector
from
collecting your your objects like it's
supposed to do you have to tell it that
it's referenced and ref is the way that
you do that
there's code around that too i really
want to just point you guys at a lot of
examples and have you kind of go in
refer to these slides and maybe it'll
make more sense but
half hour so let's keep going signatures
are the way that you
make sure that the object that you're
calling methods on
goes with your module right because
there's a disconnect between
the c plus classes and the functions
because javascript is so dynamic
i can i can take you know a function and
detach it from this object and call it
right
and javascript is not going to know that
it goes with that that
object because there's a c plus class
under it and if i try to reference it
it's going to crash it doesn't know that
so there's so signatures are really
important
also but the the thing is you can get
really far without doing any of this
stuff
and you feel awesome about it and it's
working until it doesn't
and so you have to start finding all of
these
techniques to to shore up your code and
make it more robust so i'm throwing this
stuff in here
but as you guys dig in like you know i'm
trying to get the conversation started
here so i know about this stuff when you
run into it like please let's start
talking about it
um so uh all right um
there's lots more slides but let's let's
let's stop and kind of look at some code
here and see if we can get through at
least a little bit
right all right um so i've got
i've got bcrypt here right um there's
several files here
there is uh there's a there's a dot h
file which is the headers for
blowfish and uh bcrypt there's bcrypt.cc
which is the actual implementation of
bcrypt it has those two
that gen salt and that encrypt function
in c that i showed
before and uh there's blowfish here
so um this is the
that's the the that's the extent of the
c library
that's it right and then these two files
are your node
add-on so these five files
if you put the right things in them you
get this little module that will do
decrypt for you um and i think that's
really cool
so let's see uh how far i can get hang
on just a sec
hello can you hear me all right cool
cool uh
those are my slides let's let's get rid
of those um
uh this is emacs so god help me if i
can't get through this
but uh yeah i'm i'm gonna blow them up
um
let me just find what i need first um
let's look at uh the h file
um which i don't have open sweet
all right so source decrypt node h
all right so here's our here's our
header file right here's what we want
our module to do
it's going to have a class it's going to
be called bcrypt
oh yeah sorry uh nope that didn't work
um there we go yeah all right
um i do i do use emacs i don't have to
blow it up very often so
um so here we go um
you've got your bcrypt object and you've
got you you subclassing object wrap so
that it it will
behave sanely when you want it to stick
around right
uh and there's there's three there's
three functions here right there's
there's a static version
of initialize which we'll see in just a
second that's how you're going to
essentially initialize your your module
and populate it with methods
um there's a new function which is your
constructor for this bcrypt object and
in javascript when you call newbiecrypt
it's going to call this new function
okay and there's encrypt
which is the the v8 version of this
encrypt function that you're going to
call so these
if you remember the slides that's the
extent of what this module does you get
an object
create one called encrypt that's it
right
so this is the extent of what we need
for this um
now uh let's look at
the c file
okay um i'm gonna i'm gonna go pretty
fast there's not a lot to to look at
here
um oh this is the wrong file sorry
uh yeah here we go
all right um here's what the c code
looks like
a couple headers don't worry about that
using namespace so you don't have to
type
v8 colon colon everywhere node colon
colon everywhere
here's your initialized function all
right let me start let me start with a
nit actually
here's a knit way at the bottom it has
an extern
uh it's it's called init and it gets a
handle object which is your target
this maps directly to module.exports
it's the it's the javascript version of
that or is the c plus version
of that so we're going to hang methods
off of here and when you do require
decrypt
this is the object that you're going to
get and all we do in this init function
like i said this is just a portal in
is we initialize it by passing it into
initialize
right there's here's where we get into
to v8 um i'm you know i i can't do too
much to explain this because i have five
minutes but
um here are the here are the things that
are happening here right we're making a
function template
and what this says is we're making a new
function template and what we're passing
it in
is our function new that's this
we're telling it we're making a new
javascript function template that's
going to be mapped directly
to this c plus new function okay
so when we when we call new be crypt
it's going to call this
um we have to do some some v8 stuff like
set some internal fields um you'll learn
about that
um there's some other this is our gen
salt function which i commented out
and node set prototype method is a one
of those handy macros that node
gives you to do these types of things
easily
so it's going to take our function
template it's going to create a new
property called encrypt
and encrypt is going to map directly to
our
encrypt function that we're going to
look at in just a second so when you
call encrypt on this object
it's going to map to this c plus
function so
um so there's that and then finally so
what we have now what we have now
is a new a new constructor essentially
right when we do new bcrypt that's this
this is a function template right
we've mapped it to encrypt
so we've got a function called encrypt
and then
what we what we're creating now is a new
symbol called bcrypt
mapping it to our constructor and then
we're good to go we've got our
constructor here
we've got our encrypt function here
we've hooked them up and then we've
attached that
off of this target target.set decrypt
git function
cool pretty much sweet all right
so new is really simple
we create our handle scope we always
need those
we create a new bcrip c plus plus
object and then we wrap it
so this is a function that comes off of
object wrap and it says take the c plus
plus function
and wrap this handle around it
and the handle that we want is the
context of this new function
okay so args.this is going to return our
handle we're going to pass it into wrap
and now we have a javascript handle
with our c object underneath and they're
going to go together until they get
collected
okay and then we return our object
you have to do this and you don't have
to do this explicitly in javascript you
have to do this in
c plus to return your object when you do
constructors uh
encrypt this is the meat of it this is
the only thing that this
this module does handle scope
unwrap our bcrypt object because this
we're calling decrypt.encrypt
unwrap it by calling unwrap and we've
got we have to tell it it's a decrypt
object
right you've seen this now we have our c
plus plus object
now we're going to pull the arguments
out the first one is our password second
one is our salt
all of this is dealing with see
conversion from js to c types all of
this
okay turn it into a string because it's
of type handle
value value is the highest you know the
highest level in the hierarchy of values
in v8
so it's a value turn it into a string we
know it's a string because we're
you know we built this and we're writing
the code for it
if you don't know what it is this gets
way harder but we know what it is
um you data and you salt i'm turning
into utf-8 values
and then i'm pulling those out into char
stars you have to go through these steps
usually
right you can write a macro around it
but essentially we went from javascript
strings
to v8 to uh c char stars now we have
we have our data right and then this is
the library
call b crypt on those two things and get
back at charstar
uh sorry um so i think the rest of this
makes a lot of sense right
we're creating a new string with our new
decrypted
value and we're returning it that's it
like
you just you just created a module right
i didn't get to
how to build this and i don't think
that's bad because that part sucks
um but definitely come talk to me let's
look at this stuff i'm gonna post all
the slides which have way more
information about all the stuff that i
did not get to
but um if do we have any time for
questions at all
what's that
oh yes uh it is going to be at um
it is not up yet it is going to be at
it is going to be on github yes um
it's it's in one of these slides where
it will be the repository is there it's
just empty
i'm going to put the slides up what's
that
polo tech it's on the first slide that's
me
everywhere twitter github irc whatever
so
come talk to me we need to do more of
these